So, that's gradient descent. As we mentioned, gradient descent is
just one machine learning technique and one of the most basic.
There are a number of sophisticated machine learning algorithms for
predicting and classifying our data points. And if this is interesting
to you, I'd really recommend you to go out there
and read more about machine learning, and really dive into some
of those algorithms. Let's talk about Assignment 3. In this
assignment, you'll use methods we learned during this lesson. So the
t-test and linear regression using gradient descent, to make some conclusions
and predictions about our data. First you'll use the t-test in
order to compare various sub sets of our subway data to
try and make some conclusions about subway ridership. For example, do
people ride the subway more if it's raining? Or maybe they
ride more if it's the weekend. Then we'll use linear regression
to try and build a model that predicts how many total
riders the New York City subway will have. On a particular
day and time, given a variety of factors. For example, the time of
day, whether or not it's a weekday, how the weather is, et cetera.